[Musique]
et bien tout d'abord merci à tous
d'avoir répondu présent à l'appel c'est
bien normal
pourquoi lui en lui c'est bon c'est pas
commencer à faire voler ce qu pardon
ensuite j'ai un petit problème avec
l'autorité
à part la grande guerre ferait que vous
en aviez pris plein la gueule mais c'est
juste que j'aime pas qu'on me donne
désormais tout à fait un joueur
d'indépendantistes voilà way ou un gros
con way s'il vous plaît on a du boulot
donc je disais merci à tous d'être venus
mais alors et nous allons enfin pouvoir
régler ensemble la question des humains
encore si j'avais su hurlus excusez moi
n'en avait pas déjà réglé le problème
je croyais qu'ils n'étaient pas assez
évolué ou je sais pas quoi toutefois
cela dit quand on vous voit on peut se
reposer la question mais la question
justement c'est qu'il commence vraiment
à avoir des doutes donc pour la énième
fois qu'est ce qu'on fait des humains
selon lui ouais voilà on détruit la
terre c'est bien allons-y en finesse
pour une fois ça dépend ils sont combien
environ 7 milliards parfois on peut se
permettre un petit sacrifice vivant lui
attendra pas commencé à parlementer pour
7 milliards c'est non mais attendez il
n'a jamais été question de détruire la
terre régler le problème s'est
rapidement aux déjà qu'est ce qu'on sait
d'eux alors apparemment certains d'entre
eux croient en une espèce de barbus
cosmique qui ferait les choses
extraordinaires mais comme sont pas
d'accord sur le sujet bas ils se foutent
sur la gueule sur la même planète
oui il sait qu'il aura mis ça en tête
pardon j'avoue le barbu c'est ma faute
mission d'infiltration qui a mal tourné
comment je pouvais savoir qui marchait
pas sur l'eau mois et ben voilà
l'infiltration ça c'est une bonne idée
ça nous permettra de vérifier leur
évolution depuis la dernière fois alors
qu'il veuille aller hurlus l'attendait
faites pas vos timide c'est un peu comme
prend des vacances des vacances ton et a
vu les engins qui ce travail là bas ne
pas faire de maître sentir tiré au cul
sinon y'a roswell il est jamais revenu
reçoivent
oui vase une wii du coup pas rejoigne et
quoi bob ils n'arrêtent pas de lire dans
mes pensées à n'importe quoi messi jouer
bas soient pas dupes remontée entre
elles soit pas pour longtemps c'est la
maman tiger calmez vous y en a pas un
pour rattraper l'autre là vous êtes
sensé l'élite de la galaxie vous
comprenez ça et là il ya personne pour
faire avancer le débat
guéant lui non par contre moi j'ai une
idée pourquoi est-ce compter les
porterai pas un humain c'est une idée de
compte c'est une bonne idée c'est une
idée de moi ce que tout à l'heure tu
peux utiliser quand c'est si bon ça
c'est bien qu'est ce qu'on lui demande
après pas où on lui demande de défendre
selon lui les valeurs de l'espèce
humaine voir s'il mérite va mendier des
combats sont aulas ont choisi un homme
ou une femme dure lui non mais on n'a
qu'à prendre quelqu'un au hasard pour
pas être influencée et ben voilà
excellente idée bon bah si ça va tout le
monde vous êtes partout
[Musique]